ah welcome to today number two of our
mini quartz and today I want to spend
the first part of the hour talking about
typing mathematics because yesterday we
were talking about typing straight copy
I have to incur to me in the middle of
the night that I lied in one respect
yesterday and I and I being a very
honest man I have to admit that that
well I told you about quotation marks is
is almost always true but not always
true namely that if you type two things
to get opening quotes but that's it
depends on the font you're using some
fonts don't have that it don't have that
built in the same thing with dashes if
you're using a are so-called typewriter
type font and then you type in a two
hyphen so you get two hyphens but if
you're using an ordinary kind of fun you
type two hyphens you get in it an in
dash and so each font actually is what
tells the it either that the designer
the font has told tech what what
combinations are there tech doesn't have
these things built into it so so people
can make up fonts that do that do
strange things like our Russian our
Cyrillic font has special combinations
that you type to get special letters in
Russia and in fact on the Russian fun if
you type to to open quote marks you get
a Russian looking quotation marks which
is which are French it's a little little
lovely little tip these V symbols and
stuff so so each font has its own
built-in things like that so otherwise
tech couldn't possibly know how much
space to leave out between us to quote
marks out for each fun it would look
funny and sometimes not so the designer
the font really tells tech all about all
these multiple letter combinations that
are that are there okay otherwise I
think I told the truth yesterday now
today I want to get mathematics and I
and I and I decided that what i would do
is i go to my beloved calculus book that
I use when I was a freshman in college
and and since this is a kind of
mathematics that seems to be common to
so many technical papers and this what
this book was actually a quite of a
beautiful piece of typography and it's
one of the reasons I guess that I always
that I went with the publisher I did
because I remembered
that I like the books that they printed
when I was a student and so I looked at
the book and I said that's about eight
hundred pages long so I'll just choose
look at page oh you go to page 400 right
in the middle of the book and I'll use
that for my example so i looked at page
four hundred and then but i have to tell
you this because I get in on being very
honest you see I at least I'm telling
you anything honest and and I'm but on
page four hundred it was a little bit
too complicated for what I really wanted
to to present on the first on the first
lecture so I decided okay well let's
look at page two hundred okay so page
two hundred is what I want to start out
with as a first example of mathematics
well get to page four hundred later
though so page two hundred that can we
have it on the screen so you can see
what we happen to be in page two hundred
is called applications of integration to
physics and it starts out with three
illustrations well now I'm not going to
tell you how to do these illustrations
with tech in fact you can't mean tech
isn't going to draw a very very nice
line like that however we one of our
grad students did a thesis this last
spring of which actually wouldn't would
make all three of these figures very
nicely and another one of our students
David wall if you look at his thesis in
the library he actually did all of his
illustrations in his thesis with the
meta font program as if these were
letters of the alphabet and and and and
made a big type fonts especially for his
thesis side just containing the
illustrations in it but anyway we're
going to start on the next line after
the illustrations and just to saying it
that work is in progress on how to do
technical illustrations also but for now
let's assume that we've got a good art
department that's going to do this all
beautifully for us with their air
brushes and all this thing now ok so now
I want to go through this page and maybe
I'll try an experiment where I'll just
ask you to tell me I might go through
the class here and and unless people are
two are too nervous about it and I'll
just ask them to
you know tell me how we would type each
of these things now I'll uncover the
answer as I as we go let's see if I can
set up a little thing here now okay so
let's see if I can if I can work this
out so I started out my file by saying
input basic that's what I suggest that
you all do on your sample file then the
next line I I the site ed this next line
afterwards I saw that i was going to
need a new font down here that isn't in
basic see what's his example one caps
and small caps on so I I input a new
font there forget that for the time
being and the next line is something I
told you about yesterday that I could
use a double arrow this is a special
incantation that you can put at the
beginning of a file you don't have to
copy down now because there will be a
hand out later that has its own you
don't have to copy down any of this
actually I think you can just pay
attention to you want to worry about
copy but this is an incantation which
said when i type a double arrow it's
going to it's going to tell tech not to
break between between those two words at
the end of a line if in the success will
be necessary so so i started out that
way and then now we got to get to the
beginning of this of this line here well
this first sentence of course there's
nothing there's nothing very very
interesting about it it starts out so so
we just type it in right other
applications of the moment of inertia to
physical problems or letter we get the
paragraph in denta okay the paragraph
indent is is part of the basic format
basic format sets up a certain paragraph
indentation it's actually I think it's
about almost 2 m's which is maybe too
too large if you don't like it you have
to change it and you say power indent 1m
or whatever you want for your paragraph
indentation but basic has its own idea
as to what a good paragraph indentation
is and it's sort of a style that's been
preset for you all of these other facts
of the style though can can be changed
for now we're just going to assume that
somebody somebody gave us their favorite
style so basically every paragraph will
be indented what the problem is if you
don't want it indented then you have to
say don't indent okay no so a blank line
at the beginning I wouldn't have even
needed this blank line because at the
very beginning tech is ready for a new
paragraph but but a blank line ends up
ends of paragraph and puts you back in
the into the condition you were at the
beginning okay so so at the very
beginning so it's always so so in other
words the fact that I type this capitulo
here and it wasn't preceded by a
backslash it says oh this is the
beginning of a paragraph anything yeah
when I said centerline or something else
like that it wasn't starting up a
paragraph yesterday's examples but this
capitulo is what switches it into a new
paragraph then when we get to the end of
that paragraph was a blank line there it
goes back to this to the starting
condition saying well so then we can
give instructions like give a little
extra space it was coming in okay so now
okay now anybody remember what I do and
I get to this next line when you say CEO
look I guess we needed a little bit
larger yeah I'm going to tip it a little
bit so that you can see more of the line
it's okay in your screen that's okay
this without fictive I think it's okay
you can I it's me to look out at the
audience here and see everybody
okay now if I go like this what do you
do right there okay all right yeah all
right um anyway what do we do to get
this in italics this is a book by series
of mechanics heat and where I'll go on
sound okay now how do i how am I going
to get that into italics is anybody let
me put me so I'll go sequentially
through and don't I hope you don't mind
if when when it comes to you turn it's
either very hard or very simple question
because we just do it for fun of first
I'll put you know pick up your mic ins
okay i would i would write open
parenthesis see sears comma then begin
with the open brace open brace yeah slip
back / SL space and then within the good
okay why do you say backslash SL of
course let it slanted tight okay and and
and there's also but this is an italic
type voices for your IT so so i haven't
talked about the different transplanted
in italic type there but no sign of type
is it but and some people think thing
it's the same thing now there's two
different styles of type 1 is 1 is just
like the ordinary Roman but but its tip
like your heads are tip right and the
other one is is quite a different style
the the beginnings of the letters go go
in strokes like that and so on and
that's a that's a metallic now typically
italic is used in mathematics let's take
a look at here's an example of the tech
output for this pay you see the X there
that's not it's quite different from an
ex that you find em here is quite
different from that M ok but now up here
is a slanted is an example of slanted
type you look at the at the a for
example the oil etsy we have any
anything that gives that here's an M do
I have an M no I just in any way slanted
sign it Roman type is a different thing
so now now this is something that that
you that you might not like some
somebody's might might just prefer to do
it the old way and just use italic and
there is a 10 you'd say it4 italic I in
this example I used sl4 slanted just to
illustrate the difference that I could
tell you about the difference between a
telecon slanted and and in the
I've been experimenting now that it's
easy to do with computers it was very
hard to do with the old printing
equipment but now there's easy i was
experimenting with with using Roman type
for a normal text slanted type for
emphasis or four titles of other books
and italic type for mathematical symbols
the reason to have a distinction for
this is important in mathematics usually
because a statement of a theorem or a
main result is often in italics as same
as the variables and you can't tell the
difference between the the formulas and
the italic sin that case but if you have
slanted for the statement of the theorem
then they then the formula will still be
distinguishable from this front from the
statement of theorem and on the other
hand people say well you shouldn't go
overboard and change fonts all the time
why have so many fonts and it's true you
can go overboard but slanted seems to
blend reasonably well with Roman and so
some people have have gone halfway and
they say and they like to use slanted
just for titles of books and things in
the bibliography which 10 but they use
at alexs for emphasis and italics for
formulas or something anyway you have
this this extra freedom now that you can
use it or not if you if you want and in
this case in my example I use slanted
which comes out slightly different from
this which is it Alex ok and now where
do you where do you put a close brace
you status an open brace before the
mechanics but where do you close that
brace I would put it after a media after
the da sound after the DN sound ok yeah
otherwise you get this comma in in
italics now you do get the commas in in
mechanics heat and sound and if so if if
that was actually it you know it if you
look closely here I think those are
italic comments but it's very it's very
difficult to notice and and you can even
get a headache
and so yeah yeah often they'll say if
you put on a telecon a comma there and
they're not sure what to do on a
semicolon sometimes they sometimes they
sometimes they make the italic exam I
call and sometimes they don't now if
this were a semicolon we could get into
trouble because the D the D might might
bump into the semicolon okay and there's
a little thing that I haven't done in
this example because it was followed by
a comma and you didn't arise but if at
the end after you're doing at alexs in
the end with a D or something that looks
like it's going to stick out well before
the right brace you put back slash
forward slash which is called the italic
correction add the italic correction and
this will add whatever whatever is the
appropriate amount of space for the
preceding letter so that in case you
wanted to follow that by semicolon it
wouldn't bump into it okay but you but
but you do this like if it's followed by
I'm afraid you have to use your own
judgment on it sometimes you want and
sometimes you don't and and tech will do
it we will look sometimes in some fonts
will will say look for a quote mark fall
or something like that when it's more
important sometimes but but usually you
catch this if there seem to be a little
bit to a bad clash all of a sudden
menyukai you put in your tail attraction
that's a refinement that that's that
sometimes you notice anyway okay so that
was a vet's in examples I'm sorry if I
bring in always the hard cases i'm being
a little too honest I think sometimes in
this in flexure but you've got to also
realize that that all rules have
exceptions and sometimes I can probably
go overboard and thinking the exceptions
when I state the rule okay now anything
else coming up here well not really so
bad and then we get to a displayed
formula now this is a little bit hard
I'm going to start with simple formulas
and then go to the disco back to the
display in a minute so we're going to
come back to this display in a minute
but meanwhile let's go on to the next
line it says in which I is the moment of
inertia and I is a simple formula you
see that letter I all by itself that is
a formula as a mathematical formula it
happens to be a look rather trivial but
but it's a formula so Carolyn how
type that one any idea is it just a
slanted eye okay you could say slanted
eye because that's what it is it slanted
eye but that's not psychologically right
okay let me let me explain in the first
place in the first place I want to point
out that that that since mathematics
used to cost a lot of money for
typesetting text convention about
mathematics is that mathematical
formulas are surrounded by dollar signs
okay so so you put a dollar sign before
and after a mathematical form okay now
try again the dollar sign capital I
dollars yeah that's it okay so there's
the end so that so so that did it no
it's very simple formula you just you
know oh can we have it on screen okay so
it's just dollar sign high dollar sign
now inside the dollar signs special
rules apply yeah in mathematics special
rules apply inside a dollar signs and
tech will truck will will do what's
ninety-nine percent of the time the
correct thing for mathematics for
spacing and so on when you first see a
printer that hasn't done mathematics
before and he comes up with formulas
they look funny to a mathematician but
but it's hard to say exactly why they
just look funny and then the printers
who did know mathematics will have
learned over the years this but like the
the conventions for putting your
workspace in the right place and antec
has also learned these rules and and
again all rules have exceptions but 99%
of time it will it will do the right
thing for the for you in the formula and
we'll see only one or two exceptions
today that and and there the manual
talks about them now of course in a
formula like this there isn't much much
room for error I think any printer would
get that one right
although it I the italic correction was
at it in fact I mean actually that you
know that the eye doesn't just the
baseline of the eyes and Senator the
italic correction is center button now
another thing is inside of in between
inside of the dollar signs you have very
you don't have you don't have to care
about spaces that you leave in there at
all because tech thinks it knows better
than you so if you put spaces in there
it's going to ignore them anyway so so
you could say dollar signs base
capitalize space dollar sign and it
would still come out exactly the same
but the space is before and after the
docs sign are our part of your ordinary
paragraph and those and if you left out
the space after that dollar sign it
would it would you know throw throw the
words together I is something like that
yes I am now ok the next line we got
this is too simple to ask you Jeff so so
G is the acceleration due to gravity l
is the distance notice you use an L here
that comes out to be near your italic L
it's not confusing with the one like it
is on a typewriter but if somebody wrote
a script Dell and you def definitely
once a script dell has a loop in it then
there's it then you have a control
sequence for for script I'll scrl which
would give you the script ale now
actually in when I'm writing a
manuscript from giving it to my
secretary I typically use a script dell
so that so that it won't look like a one
but then she'll type it as a script dale
and then i'll remember saying actually
now that is going into tech it's okay
you know italic a look lik alright and
then I in and I know so now i tell her
when I mean a script ll put a note on
the side saying I really mean a script l
today but usually I usually italic else
are are are okay in in something like
tech but on your other typewriter maybe
not unless you had some kind of a
Selectric where you're changing the
balls or something okay lift up a
question of
the court you laze about scripted and L
how do you actually type in a dollar
sign / back / if you want we go out of
the next if you want a dollar sign you
say back / dollar sign in you like if
you want to say one dollar you know if
you're writing a very you're writing a
paper on economics you know something
like that and you say we have to say one
dollar like you you could well you could
put this outside of them so you have to
get into math mode and then this is
treated as a special character in mass
mode and there are a few of these
symbols that are actually treated as as
mathematical symbols even though
sometimes they aren't consider i mean
you can you there's a pound sign to a
sterling i think you call it s TRL if
you get your in England you know and
there's a there's a sign that called
section these are all listed in the
manual in the sign called section that
goes like that and that is considered a
mathematic symbol so you go I signs
around it in order to get it okay
Phyllis you had a question remember to
use the mic oh that's uh that's right I
type it more than you do in fact that's
right I forgotten this one completely
it's LSC I thank very much in fact
otherwise I wouldn't know because
otherwise the upper Kate there's an
uppercase script l2 and if and if and
tech would know the difference between
up between this and with an uppercase so
the Technos the difference with the
first letter is uppercase or not but
other letters it doesn't so so you're
elsker this way with a small out okay
right thank you very much that saved me
at least an hour of sleep tonight
okay now okay now now let's look ahead
here they looked at it's a little extra
space between these two okay so how
would we get that Jeff oh wait wait I'm
sorry before I go to that no this will
be this will be your this will be your
question now Jeff excuse me look at this
dash in here in the figure 5-11 you see
anything unusual about that what is
there anything like that anything
different to type when you type to see
figure 5 5 11 you it is slightly longer
than a yeah right this is an n dash this
is an end is one of the context where n
dash is typically used printer won't use
a hyphen there good proof reader would
think it looks funny with a hyphen there
so how do you can end dash so you use to
huhot yes so I said okay right okay and
then I also put a I also put my double
arrow between it because that that
that's that's to avoid first of all
getting an extra too much space after
the abbreviation f IG and also it
wouldn't break a line in cases came at
the end of a line it wouldn't put a
break between fig and 5 11 f to be on
the next line all right now on the other
hand since this is an n dash it's
possible that it would break after after
that before the 11 that would be a
pretty bad a pretty pretty lousy looking
great and if it did that then I would go
back and put that in an H boxes saying
forbid the break but it's the chances
are pretty bad that it lacked that it'll
ever happen Tech only chooses
hyphenating things if it's if it's
really necessary so I didn't bother to
to to do that although although it's
possible that I would get a break after
that n dash that I didn't want okay next
question how would I get this little
extra space here notice I did leave an
extra line here because I came to the
end of a paragraph okay now i got i want
to leave a little extra space between
this in the next paragraph i would use a
back / v skip point of something yeah
okay well this is actually typical style
here would be about three points extra
three points doesn't seem like much 72
points to an inch three points is so
twenty fourth of an inch doesn't seem
like much but actually a little space
actually is quite noticeable three
points worth is certainly noticeable and
so I so you got so V skipped three
points who did it now to get the next
this next is in nine point type instead
of 10.5 this example is in smaller type
size but basic only has one type size so
I just left it in the same type size if
you're setting up though for a book your
your font designer would tell you at
this point actually you probably have a
special style that you would go through
for examples and that would
automatically switch you to nine point
type and change all the funds but I'm
going to ignore that and just continue
on in 10 points so let's go on example
one does anybody know what I do to get
to start our example one without an
indentation you say no indent right so I
say no indent that's another way to
start a paragraph to say no indent and
that starts a parrot starts you off in a
paragraph and there's no indentation in
the paragraph well then then this cap
some small caps i said i invite i
invented them visiting dallas job Barney
you put a slash before the know and and
here it is yep here it is you see that
no / knowing that because it otherwise
it would it would type noi and be it
would be indented even yeah okay now
here I had a caps in small caps type use
okay and so and so I so here I'm doing
none so I switched to find em now the
backslash colon is a way of switching to
a fun I could have also made up a
control sequence meaning switch to caps
and small caps font but I just showed
you this because i define font capital m
at the beginning of this page to be this
font icsc mcse which is the caps and
small caps fun the when you if you go
over the room by the dover on the wall
there's a there's a there's a book that
that has examples of all the fonts that
are available now but i only needed this
actually it's not in basic and I I don't
expect you'll needed in your in your own
cases just in to mimic what's in the
book and typically the designer the book
would even would even set up a special
control sequence just for example so you
would say begin example or something
like that a new type example one and the
control sequence will take care of
everything we do the no indent it would
insert the three points and it would it
would also put a little extra space
after it nestled next thing I want to
talk about this quad here now now this
is a little extra space after that
example one and the book designer and
and and one-quarter space is about the
same width as an em dash and but it's
blank instead of being a dash and and it
depends on the font that you're using so
I said quad here that gave me a little
extra space after the one well now the
rest is pretty straightforward but I'm
just telling you the new things we're
coming along here we have a simple math
formula l okay now we're going to get to
a real math formula in a minute so then
we go into solution okay you can already
tell what's going to come there we ended
this paragraph then we said we skip
another three points and then we said
knowing them to can slanted for solution
or you could have had at Alec if you
wanted for solution and a quad there ok
now we typing away and now we get to a
the real well here's what here's a
slightly more complicated formula can
anybody read this pose the rod coincides
with the x-axis let's get this a little
larger we can yeah okay now here's
x-axis how would you type that let's see
here I forget your name or your next
yeah okay you would put one dash in
between yeah this is a debt this is a
this is a high 49 and m def but how do i
get 2x I don't just type in X / IL space
out well I would use a dollar sign okay
but that is it yeah so so I I would use
the dollar sign and type it like this
okay x axis okay oops showing the next
time all right x axis alright so that's
again it's a simple platform but you can
combine it with with words if you want
to because it's just there's no space
after okay now where are we here okay
from x equals 0 2 all right now this
whole x equals 0 that that
thing is an equation and so typically
they'll be slightly different spacing
around the equal sign but tech is going
to be the one that's going to be
responsible for putting in the spacing
the proper spacing around the equal sign
okay so next how would you type that
little equation x equals zero you have
the mics dollar sign x yeah okay but
then i but then i see i do put the whole
thing inside so I say dollar sign x
equals zero and then another dollar sign
and then Tech will automatically know
the right amount of spacing and how much
it should get should grow and shrink as
as appropriate for for an equal sign
okay from x equals 0 to x equals l and
so that's again very simple all right I
see that that's going a little slowly so
I'm not going to go through the
classroom it was fun for a while though
now divide okay now divide the interval
can you can you predict though with me
exactly what's going to happen divide
the interval 0 less than or equal X less
than or equal l into okay so here we see
a mathematical formula so instinctively
type dollar sign then we type 0 then
less than or equal we happen to have a
less than or equal on our keyboard at
sale it's very hard to live without it
once you've had it but if you don't have
it you can make up a control sequence
that will say leq or something for less
than or equal but in my examples here on
type doing it all out sale where we have
our less than or equal symbol and so we
we type that this way 0 less than equal
x less than equal L okay and into some
sub intervals are with Delta X now
here's a new here's something we got a
Greek letter Delta okay now those people
who are done a lot of technical typing
will probably know from other people
that it's called Delta other people than
a lot of technical type you never learn
the name of it in Greek but they know
what it looks like and they're used to
and they're used to it bison bye-bye
triangle or whatever they want to call
it okay now a list of Ali's but symbols
is in the back is in one of the
appendices of the manual you worry
queered if you see a symbol that
somebody throws at you that you that you
don't know the name of you can look it
up its appendix f for all the fun
information it's in the back of it and
then there's also so it tell this is a
capital Greek letter and it's called
Delta and we type that as a capital
capitalized d capital Delta okay x now
on I have to mention that some I had a
debate with this with one of the men who
does a lot of typesetting of
mathematical journals and and he says
that it's easy that that he prefers to
have completely put a random names for
all of these for all these special
characters that his type is learned
because that gives them a feeling of
power over the mathematicians and that's
it and and and they get more job
satisfaction from that but but since
we're work we're expecting also
mathematicians are going to understand a
little bit about tech as well so we
chose our names for these symbols the
same as the mathematician would use a
capital Delta okay so so Delta X there
there they are they get typeset that way
okay now here we have Delta M same thing
question yet okay the space between the
end of the Delta and the X there okay
now what if I didn't put a space in
there anybody got an idea error message
undefined control sequence Bell tax it
doesn't understand Delta X yeah so
here's a case where where where it's
where spacing inside the dollar sign did
did make some difference if there wasn't
a space there then the control sequence
we change its name yeah so that space
was essential you could have put two
spaces there are spaces before and
before the Delta or something like that
wouldn't make any difference but but
that one is necessary just because it's
a control sequence right okay so Delta M
the same thing the Delta M denote the
mass between X and X plus Delta X okay x
plus delta x you see that's typed in
this obviously okay
in the moment of inertia of Delta M
differs from x squared delta m by an
infinitesimal now here is I think the
only exception noil one of the one of
two exceptions I'll talk about today in
mathematics typing that is when you have
a formula but if you had just typed this
x squared delta m to tech it would not
have put a little space between the x
squared and the delta sign there but
it's been traditional in mathematics
that whenever you have a delta an
infinitesimal you specified by delta or
by d like diem you put a little space in
front of it to separate it off from the
rest of the formula so somebody would
say X DX there will be a little extra
space there between the X and the D then
if if they were all together in a
formula meaning x times D times X
because DX is it means something to
mathematician so when you type in
calculus things you have Delta's or
something else in front of it you have
to sometimes remember that that there's
a space there that that's a matter of
judgment as to whether this is a you
know sometimes you put it in an
infraction you don't if you're saying
delta x over delta y you don't put it in
front of the in front of the Delta Y so
so I had to adjust the spacing there but
first of all the x squared I guess I
ought to mention that to get a
superscript you say up arrow so up arrow
to out there or two and gives you x
squared then I put this thin space
between after the two and before the
Delta so this this backslash comma is
means a thin space backslash comma is
what you stick in if you like a little
more space the backslash ! is the
opposite it take means take out a thin
space and put it together move back up
by thin space so backslash comma is a
thin space there's also a thick space
backslash semicolon which is the typical
space that you actually have around
equal signs and around unequal signs
there's a thick spit they if you can see
you can see the thick space here
before after the 0 and B before that
less than or equal sign answer thick
space the thin space is typically used
in front of their it's a little bit
thinner it's a space between if you have
a if you have something like log X as a
thin space between the word log and X
tech will put that one in for you
automatically but here I had to put this
thin space in because it's a convention
in calculus before D X or Delta X or
something like that you put it within
space ok now here's the next one Delta X
right arrow 0 now we again we have a
right arrow sign on our on our machine
so we just type it we just type it easy
way otherwise if you're doing it at
score or some other place you don't have
it on a keyboard at Xerox I guess you
don't do you would type our t arrow or
whatever they call it there and and you
have have a control sequence that
somebody would have to make up for if
you don't have it that would they would
get you this this symbol but as far as
Tyga is concerned this symbol is pretty
much like an equal sign it has the same
spacing around it as equal signs do ok
for homogeneous right a constant cross
section also Delta M equals Rho Delta X
here's again a thin space after the row
ok now i type row thin space Delta X Rho
is is one of those characters I don't
have on my keyboard so I had a type Rho
ok didn't have Delta either for that
matter and then m / L Rho equals m / elk
but I guess the obvious way to type that
ok now we get to something more
interesting hence ah now we get this
this is a displayed formula now
displayed formulas are even more
expensive so so you go in the old days
so they would usually meant a lot of
handwork especially so that so we put
two dollar signs before and after it is
blade ok but double dollar sign means
this is a display something that means
you stop your paragraph where you are
essentially tells texas has stopped the
car for you are add a little extra space
and center something that's coming after
ok now let's do this display formula
one step at a time I said why so down
arrow for subscripts I told you about up
here for superscripts but a down arrow
gives gives I sub y equals that's easy
now we've got this integral sign here
okay integral sign is int and then
integral signs have these other things
on which we treat just like subscripts
and superscripts so you can give the
superscript first of the subscript first
it doesn't matter i gave here i gave the
0 the subscript first so i say sub-zero
super l ok all these examples by the way
have a simple one character as a
subscript if it was more than one
character i would just put it hoping in
braces tech will if you don't put it in
braces techo since the very first
character is is the super scoop i put a
space after this l but that didn't mean
anything to tech no it's a space in is
akin in a double dollar sign same as in
dollar signs it doesn't matter a space
tech boom you know will ignore that
space does its own spacing here is x
squared okay superscript 2 and then in
front of the DM I want to have a thin
space this is a calculus convention in
front of a differential you put a thin
space so i put my thin space in there
again it's the equal sign well the next
one is where is almost you know this is
trivial this is integral sub-zero super
l x squared here i didn't leave a space
between the eleanii x just to show you
that tech doesn't know it doesn't you
know if it's if the l isn't in braces
it's going to it's only one symbol on
the superscript only last one symbol
unless you put a brace there and get
more complicated formula and then x up
super super to row again no space there
so the that's why the superscript is
only a two and a little thin space
before the DX okay now we got something
new with fraction here Rho L cubed over
3 and what you what you do there is you
use the word over over the backslash in
it in fact it looks very much like that
one except
except is this one and now I put the
whole thing in braces I put the whole
fraction in braces so that tech would
know where the fraction begins and where
the fraction ends and then I said ro L
cubed over 3 double dollar sign to end
the display the whole thing gets Center
and properly spaced out okay now this is
uh this is the the formula and and the
over you say how does over know how far
did how far to go what goes over what
well it goes to the left to look it's to
a left brace or or something there's one
other case called a backslash left that
that would that would stop over if I'd
if I didn't have those braces there and
I said ro L cubed over 3 without the
braces it would have taken this whole
son this whole formula here and then put
a bar over it into three underneath that
you had that long thing wouldn't make
too much sense mathematically but maybe
someday we'll think of something that
means but that's we over with a drill
alright so that's that's a displayed
formula now this if this same formula
had appeared in the middle of a text
without the double dollar signs it would
have gone right in that paragraph there
and only had dollar signs around it and
it also tech would have set it in a
different style tech would not have you
such big integral signs in the middle of
a paragraph as it does in a display tech
would have tick would have chosen a
small integral sign instead of a big
integral science so there's a different
style actually used in a display than in
the middle of a paragraph and there is
four styles altogether there's the
display style which is your grand and
glorious die where you use big signs and
you raise superscripts a little bit
higher actually then there's the text
style which is what you'd normally get
in the paragraph then there's the style
that's used in subscripts and
superscripts which is small smaller type
size and and you don't put thin spaces
in you don't put spaces around plus
signs in the subscripts and tech knows
that and or equal signs and then then
there's the fourth style is called the
script script style which is for the
subscripts or superscripts of subscripts
and superscripts and that's
script script style is used for for
Ollie and follow remaining levels again
2 to the 2 to the 2 to the 2 to the 2 to
the 2 1st 2 is in your regular size the
next two is in like 10 point the next
one maybe seven the next 15 point and
then you stay in five point out
afterwards we get you get smaller for
the person is knees for styles and
usually the styles are chosen
automatically appropriate to the to the
condition you put it in double dollar
sign you got display style if you if
you've got single dollar sign you got
textile textile has smaller integral
science okay now then let's continue
though it says or and then we have this
other formula and here is enough this
other formula shows it another
difference between the styles because
look at this one third here this one
third was was not in the same form as
that is that fraction L cubed over 3 the
130 is actually you know I mean if I had
stayed in the display style it would
make this one third as a big one a big
bar and a big three okay but that's read
that one third is really in text style
so in order to indicate that i had to be
so the second to line the only tricky
thing about the second line i did the my
well my guess that almost the only
tricky thing was that I went into text
style at the end of it and so effortless
equal sign I said text style 1 over 3 ml
x squared and that and that got me the
ones there otherwise the one-third of
cummins it wouldn't look so bad that way
but I wanted to mimic what what they had
here oh yeah the other tricky thing
about this is i got big parentheses
around here if i just typed the regular
parentheses and then but gun my m / l
then that would be a teeny tiny little
parentheses because as far as tech knows
that the parentheses it just just any
other symbol it does they don't have to
match particularly because it's
surprising to mathematicians how often
but it turns out we often write formulas
that that have a left parenthesis and
nothing matching and on the right hand
side sometimes are usually a left brace
and nothing matching on the right inside
or something like that often happens so
in fact tech doesn't insist that there
be a right for instance for every left
sometimes it's a right bracket something
like that but but tech does but if you
want to detect to choose the right size
of left parenthesis then you can say
left back / left and back / right and
then it chooses the size based on what's
in between them so if this were and so
so here I said back / left and then i
gave the symbol that i wanted to be a
left of and it's a left parenthesis and
I said back / right and give a
parenthesis for a right I could have
made that up some other symbol after the
right and that that says choose the
choose the proper size if there is a
whole matrix or something inside there
would choose some great big huge
parentheses for it but it chooses the
size for that for that formula so that's
that's the other thing about this line
okay now I think I'll go on a wire yeah
question oh why didn't you do that with
the integral sign well I can I do that
with the integral sign because because
the integral sign is is is considered a
is in a operator that changes to decide
sizes and displays while parentheses are
considered delimiters there's a
difference between operators and de
limiters is to kind of thing integral
sign is considered an operator so is a
big Sigma sign a big summation sign in
there and these are also explaining that
same appendix there's a list of about
ten operators and a list of a bunch of
de limiters and those are considered
different things to to mathematicians
the spacing is different around on and
so on so sorry so you learn to
distinguish one from the other that the
limiters are the things that dead that
are for grouping like parentheses
typically profession braces yes
forgotten name all right oh why didn't
you have to put those did that backslash
left parenthesis also you is used as a
brace why didn't you know it braces to
me yeah that's right backslash left and
right since they have to be they have to
to be matched just like braces do then
over who knows not to go outside of
backslash left and right that's that
over oh yeah that's a good question over
know you could you wouldn't hurt to put
braces in there but it doesn't help you
don't need I mean in between left
right you don't know another question
another question right yes on the the
textile does the the textile just apply
to the next unit textile applies from
then on after so actually the the whole
one-third ml squared is all in textile
textile that's right if I wanted to get
back into display style I could I could
I could type I could have written right
here I could have said disp style after
that would be almost indistinguishable
but the superscript of the two it would
have moved up actually they aren't in
displaced out with that to their the
superscript in display style tends to be
a little higher well I'm not sure what
they yeah they do the same in the
numerator but on the main line that's
the superscript 2 on the X there is
slightly higher than it then it would be
in the text it's a funny thing but they
do that and photos too okay so so if you
wanted that that in this place so you
can you can revert to it again or you
could put or you or you could put the
whole thing in braces like this okay it
would have been a mistake though to put
braces and then say textile 1 over 3
because then the one would have been in
textile but not the whole fraction okay
so here's two sets of braces would have
done it okay good good questions all
right now let's go back to this first
equation here this one had a square root
in this is a display also has a number
and how do we type that well the answer
is I typed it like this t equals two pi
actually there's also apply on a
keyboard but I wrote it out SQ RT for
the square root symbol and then a brace
because it's it's a square root of more
than one thing if I had square root of
just one thing I wouldn't need I which I
would just say square root 2 or
something but I i can put braces and
then I over mgl is the thing that I'm
taking the square root out okay and then
you get this equation number here in the
right margin eq number five in tech will
do the right thing if it doesn't fit
it'll drop it down on lines and things
like that so that's the way I type that
one in a sin
there's a similar formula at the bottom
of the page okay so now what happened
when I first put this into the I did
this yesterday morning and I first put
into the x GP and so I got the thing out
and it looked actually pretty much like
the printed book in fact i was amazed
that it came out looking I was lucky
this time I didn't have any bugs the
first the first pass but the but I but
looking at it there was one thing i
thought i would like to change and that
is i would like to leave a little more
space before this comma his comments
looked a little a little too close
sometimes it does sometimes it doesn't
it depends on the formula in the
environment i mean if this had been
hadn't been such a tall letter L there
it probably probably would've looked
okay to me so I decided afterwards I put
a thin space there so that was my second
proofreading you know I look at
something and I say well stick that in
so it's so easy to put in so I did it I
put a thin space in fact between the pie
in the front and the square root 2
that's that sort of optional but it
looked a little more psychologically
okay to have a little thin space there
so i added so actually after this first
pass all i had to change was the was
that that putting a thin space there and
it's okay now let's go to page four
hundred and and I'll show you why I got
a little bit scared about page 400 these
are in bold face and so we were
switching fonts also in the middle of
math mode to get this bold face okay now
all this is going to be on a handout
that you're going to be getting so I'm
going to talk a little fast but you
you'll see what I did okay so tangential
vectors I start out the paragraph just
as usual but make that in boldface this
is an n dash here tangential vectors
okay I left a quad space after the title
as the point P moves along a given curve
in the XY plane we may imagine position
as being specified by the length of park
s now actually this is a case of a
psychologically bad break I could put
the double arrow in there it wouldn't be
a good place to you
typically mathematical convention length
of Arc S or you know the the integer n
you don't want to break between between
the descriptive thing and the symbol but
some but on the other hand you say we
see that n is then you wouldn't want to
break between n and is so sometimes it's
before a short form is sometimes after
but typically a short formula there is a
psychologically bad breaking we might
them if your put put that
refinement in any way some chosen
reference point P Sub Zero on the curve
okay then you get a vector with bold
face in it and here's the way I had to
type that I had to to go out of math I
inside the formula I had to make a box
in order to get the boldface are so I
said H box of BF of our and that made of
now H box and I'll talk more about boxes
later but that that that is sort
of a general purpose way to get tech to
go to to type said something that goes
in a horizontal line it R is the case
our was only one symbol but if I had
several symbols they would all get put
into a box then put this horizontal line
into a box and treat that box as a
single unit and it can be used in the
middle of a formula so I so I said H box
boldface r equals H box boldface I X
plus h box boldface J Y and I got all
these bonuses are I and J are in bold
face in that formula okay from 0 to P of
XY and here's that the capital letter o
and P of XY if you look carefully
there's a thin space after that common
there and tech does that for you it does
you know after that comma but that's in
space got any questions but yes excuse
me what would what would have happened
if you a Shh page box but left the
braces around it every it would have
said I would have been error message
saying you can't do that in math mode
you can't change fonts in math mode okay
so bold face is a switch of font and and
we're going to talk about error messages
tomorrow the whole lecture tomorrow is
about error messages okay now
and then I got tired then I looked ahead
and I saw a bold face all over the place
and I said oh oh i wouldn't want to type
h box about BF is going to be a real
nuisance okay so then i made myself a
nice little a nice little trick that a
wizard would tell me how to do that i
could just type in infinity in front of
something I want it to be bold so I I
made up a special special thing that
those people next week will learn how to
do but the gist of it is from now on I
can just type infinity in front of it
and it's going to end and that infinity
is from now on I can't use it for for
the infinity symbol anymore but I I can
use it to make to bowl defy whatever
comes after so so to get the dr by dsi
just put it to get a bowl are I put a I
i put it in the infiniti in front of the
art okay so now I kept on typing this
and I got to use these infinities quite
often you see Delta in bold are over
Delta s and so on infinity i delta x
over infinity s that's this formula here
okay so i was getting i getting a lot of
bold face very well just by typing a
single character in front of it it was
very nice okay and then i got to this
and I said oh oh what is this funny
symbol over here I don't have that in
any my fonts and how am I going to do
this okay so now we have this metaphor
program that allows you to design a
simple but what I actually ran up doing
was was was was faking it by using a a
graph accent and putting it on top of a
rule and and so I i defined anyway a
victor operation which puts a vector
over things in a half arrow symbol which
was all based on a whole bunch of
spacing around lowering up and lowering
up and down using a graphics that in the
wrong place and putting it together now
again you just go to wizard and say give
me that symbol and that's we're done
okay and well I was kind of lucky
because it came out looking fine
okay I had to play around with this
twice I first I put the our little too
high over it but anybody came out okay
alright so now we're almost done with
this with this lesson but you see
there's something new coming up in
there's equation numbers everything is
the same as we've seen before so when
you look at the handout to see that
everything is the same until we get to
this limit a limit is a is a is
something like an operator like that
integral sign that we had before except
that it except that the things things go
underneath it instead of to the right of
it but you type it just as tech knows
that l IM well basic knows that l IM is
one of these special symbols and so you
see i just got to find the way i typed
that formula to is here so I typed limb
for backslash limb to get l IM that's in
Roman it's not italic letters that you
know those aren't italic L I am there
and then subscript on it now this time
the subscript is complicated it's not
just a single sim so I put the subscript
in braces and is Delta s right arrow 0
okay so that's the way I got the limit
there and then of then the thing that
the limit is applied to putting in
braces Delta bold are over Delta s and I
said equation number two all right and
is a unit vector and also on that's the
same thing goes on here and notice one
other thing happened now when we when we
put this arrow over over the symbol
there wasn't room for it in the next
line and and and you know the paragraph
this these two lines had to be a little
split further apart than the rest of
them and and actually tech does that
also as you see when it came out when it
came out to see the same thing the same
thing worked out with this coming out of
it all right so so now I mentioned
handout and those are those are up here
please be cut one when you leave there's
three parts to the handout first of all
the first two pages tell exactly what
code was used to type set the handout
you had yesterday so you can look at
that and see what what was to get to
to what you had yesterday and the second
Lee is a is an excerpt of this exact
calculus example we've just done and the
third thing is exactly what was typed to
text which produces the calculus hand up
alright one more quick comment those of
you who have a cow have guest accounts
on the system and suppose your initials
are ABC you should say when you first
approached the system you should you
should say L ABC / TDX this logs you in
with your initial / TX don't just use
your initials if you've got one of these
new guest accounts then when you print
things on and over it's going to go into
the slot there's a whole bunch of pigeon
holes there it goes into the slot under
t for tech guests you are called your
official name to the system is tech
guests and not under ABC but it will be
under tech guest is where you'll find
your output when you when you put it on
a dollar okay
hi here are your handouts there is a
hand up